hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll now let's
face it we've all contemplated how we
would go about committing the perfect
murder or if any of you are truly
innocents out there perhaps you've
contemplated what it would be like to be
the victim of a perfect murderer one way
or the other perfect murders are the
kinds of things that dwell in our minds
we want to know what it would be like
one of the things that we think is true
anyone who has watched TV or movies
knows it is harder these days to commit
the perfect murder than it might have
been in the past the ability of the
police and their friends to investigate
crimes is better than it ever has been
before in large part because of science
because of our ability to do chemistry
and forensic science that teaches us
something from the crime scene about
what actually went down so that's what
we're gonna talk about today ray Burks
is an analytical chemist
who moved from actually working in a
crime lab to becoming a professor at st.
Edwards University in Texas where she
continues to work in forensic hurlan
forensics her lab constructs detectors
that look for explosives drugs and other
substances of questionable repute to
help the cops catch the bad guys we're
gonna talk about different types of
poison if that's the way you want to
roll how to dispose of the body this is
a big problem for would-be murderers out
there and also the major differences
between what you watch on CSI and the
real world of a forensic investigator as
far as I can tell the major difference
involves paperwork so hopefully this is
gonna be an amusing listen usually in
podcasts my goal is that something
educational happens but I'm not quite
sure I really want this one to be very
educational let's stick with amusing
shall we hopefully this will not turn
out to be useful in your own future
planning I really don't want mindscape
podcast to be investigated by the FBI
despite our best efforts though it's
very possible where you're gonna learn
something as well as have a few
thought-provoking ideas go into your
mind alright let's go
[Music]
ray Burke's welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so very excited we're
gonna talk about chemistry and murder
murder which came first for you the
chemistry or the murder murder murder
King first murder that got you into the
chemistry murder got me into chemistry
how'd that happen so I wanted to be a
lawyer and and I was a real dorky kid I
used to go to the library on Saturday
carrying a briefcase that my parents got
me because they supported my dorkiness
and I used to go and I used to like you
know read law books and learn about
collateral estoppel and so again really
funny stuff I know very fun kid and then
in junior high I got an opportunity to
go to a junior high trip and and we went
to Washington DC which of course if you
want to be a lawyer and you're a kid
that's like my god right but then we had
an opportunity to visit FBI field office
and at the time they were kind of had a
tour a little bit of forensic science
talking about crime and and how science
could be used for that and I had never
ever before in my life thought science
was remotely interesting or useful but
this really did it for me because I was
just like what you can you can use you
know you can use science to do stuff and
I don't know why it never really hit me
before you know some some people of
course my age in the shuttle era would
have been big into space or dinosaurs or
and that never really got me but the
forensic science that really resonated
and then then from there I just went
down the the nerd rabbit hole because
this was high school junior high but
then that's when you actually actively
be a minister in chemistry for its own
sake yes because you know a lot of the
tests you know the idea that you you
didn't know what something was and you
could do some tests and figure out what
it was that really got me right the the
solving mysteries and I think that you
know it's kind of what in a weird way
being a bit of a law nerd when I was
little and watching Murder She Wrote
with my grandmother and Matlock and
there was always some lawyer running
around solving you know or some ex high
school teacher who wrote mystery novels
just up to no good so so seeing that
science could you know solve these
mysteries was really the hook that got
me interested in then that's when I
realized I'm like oh so science is like
kind of a big deal yeah
and that's probably common but you stuck
with the whole murder aspect I mean yes
I don't know exactly your trajectory
I'll figure it out before I post the
episode but you served you worked in
some kind of law enforcement capacity
yeah I was interested so you know I
chemistry and then went to graduate
school and then left graduate school and
and worked in a crime lab for a while
and so yeah I mean that's what I thought
I would do for the rest of my life was
you know be in that line of work so this
is literally the CSI stuff you know
you're you're doing the you know I
worked at a small crime lab was just
five people and you know you're doing a
lot of a little bit of everything
sometimes you get called out to a crime
scene but a lot of times you just you
know you're pulling casework that you
get assigned you go down to evidence
property you pick up the stuff yeah I
and you bring it back and and you who
know I mean you you might be doing all
kinds of things I actually did a lot of
forensic video and image analysis okay
in addition a chemical processing and
physical processing of prints again it
was a very you know kind of small and so
you kind of had to like cross-training
certain things and then we also you know
when we were called out to do you know
crime scene work that was something that
you you know you had to be requested to
go out so that and then it was usually
some type of major incident so it could
have been a homicide it could have been
say a robbery which you know threat of
violence or
something of that nature that you would
get called out and have to do kind of
all this crime scene work any
particularly memorable incidents from
that period of your life
tons of memorable incidents very few I
so I would say you know for CSI I think
you know and I knew this just from you
know really being involved in going
through education and everything is that
you know first of all and see a sight no
none of us are that good-looking none of
us have wardrobes that are that hip or
cool I never had sunglasses that neat
and you know I always used to watch
those shows and you know especially when
I was in that job and they never show
them doing paperwork and I know I spent
at least half my time documenting and
writing reports do you think you sure
would be improved if there's more
paperwork I think the show would be
improved if yes CSI paperwork yeah but I
think that was the fun part is you know
it's it's like okay so take all that cut
the episode by 20 minutes and put in
just writing reports market to work that
yeah I have no idea where I don't know
either
so then what in the world gave the idea
that what you really wanted to do was be
a professor that's so I think it's funny
because you know you I planned this
whole thing where I was gonna work in
the crime lab for a long time and
definitely when I was in graduate school
you know you kind of sometimes are
surrounded by folks that want to be in
academic and a little bit different in
chemistry because chemistry is also very
not in industries it's useful for things
other than being professionally
analytical physics yeah I didn't that
was nothing but I think you know
chemistry with his history and
applications you know there's the the
the kind of common thing is a third are
an academia a third are kind of in
government labs of thirds and in
industry so you know lots of
applications in that way and so actually
most the people that I went to graduate
school with we're not going to be
academics that it's just chemistry well
it's a little bit different for other
field so this was your PhD program you
have a PhD beyond with the crime lab
yeah and so a lot of people actually
know I left this is what not to do kids
I left
graduate school to take this super
awesome job because there's not that
many jobs and I said you know what I
will totally write my dissertation while
I'm working in a full-time job famous
last mistake ah so funny I mean I did
but it just let's just say it took a
little bit longer then then I had
deluded myself right and my advisor yeah
but yeah so I think with you know I
think most of the people in definitely
in my ph.d program or in my in the lab
that I was in you know a lot went into
you know working at say GlaxoSmithKline
or Merck or you know there's there's a
colleague that works at NIST so a big
mix academia is not the the big deal
and so that was not uncommon and and you
planned for that like in your programs
you know a lot of people are going into
industry in chemistry and so or they're
you know they're gonna be full-time
researchers but not professors nothing
you know I'm not academics and so that
was really interesting to me because
that certainly wasn't what I went to
graduate school for but I had you know I
learned a lot and I definitely when I
you know you started doing a job then I
realized hey I couldn't actually miss
doing the research and development
because when you're active case work you
just have no time certainly not doing
research no no I mean in and a lot of
people worked there so I favor work to
be getting done but your case backlog in
some places can be you know several
months if not years and and so even
though you might be best positioned to
develop some new method you have no time
or no resources in order to do that so I
missed that and and I did miss teaching
even though you know when you go to
graduate schools you know you don't
really get a PhD in teaching no more
education no
so the more successful you are the less
fatigue right so it was so it's kind of
funny to me and then you know going back
into academia I realized that wow I did
I did miss these things and it kind of
in a way snuck up on me
because it's not quite what I plan for
but I do like I like the training aspect
too of undergraduate research because I
might have principally undergraduate
institution so you know the idea of of
training folks to do field work or lab
work and you know really giving them the
opportunity to develop new skills is in
an informative way is it's really fun I
find that it's very hard you know some
days you're like I hope I am not messing
this I have a lot of responsibility but
it's also a lot of fun to see you know
people really grow into their
scholarship and and into their
profession so I do physics for a living
some people have the misimpression that
they're this is somehow close to
chemistry I know nothing about chemistry
I've never even taken a chemistry class
at the university level I took high
school chemistry so if you if you had in
mind that what you were interested in
was sort of the forensic side of
chemistry what kind of chemists would
you become another's physical and
organic inorganic and so forth I would
say analytical
so I like to call analytical chemists
the detectives of chemistry so we tend
not to make chemicals we find them okay
and we tend to find them in a sea of
other ones so you know I always joke
when when people say oh it's really hard
to find a needle in a haystack that
should actually be pretty easy because a
needle and a haystack are very different
very different but analytical chemists
it's about finding a needle particular
needle in a stack of needles yep and so
while we don't often build you know or
don't do a lot of synthesis we may build
molecules or engineer instruments that
will then be used as Detective tools
right and so I think that
analysis and then also being able to
look at the data and and treat it in a
certain way whether it's statistically
or modeling the data to then kind of
stand back and look at it what the hell
does it mean and and and really it is
sometimes that way were you just like
you you project it and you have this
thing and then you have to like step
back and look at it and it might be one
of those things where I know for sure
this has happened to me where you're
looking at the data you know it means
something and you bolt up right at 2
a.m. and it has to come to you but where
you've seen this pattern before what the
pattern indicates and then you run to
write it down because I think that you
know people who are not chemists or
scientists for a living might have a
different idea of what it means to do
chemistry the the process you're
describing it sounds much more creative
and artistic than a lot of people might
think but so when you say the pattern
you recognize the pattern in what what
are you looking at so you know there's
some times so I build sensing devices
and sometimes they're chemical sensors
so one chemical will interact with
another and give off some signal and a
lot of times it's a it's a color it
changes color or it flores's there might
be like bioluminescence or chemical some
kind of you know luminescent infant and
so you might do something like trying to
not only you might have several of those
sensors and then not just do you look at
how does it change your looking how if
one change is in relationship to another
right is there some type of pattern in
how certain sensors behave and and then
what does that tell you about what
they're interacting with because
oftentimes you're trying to design
something to find at least for me being
forensic I'm trying to find quote bad
stuff yeah weapons chemical biological
explosives scheduled stuff so how then
does the sensor respond because it's not
enough to build it and have it be
reliable and be like yep it always does
it always turns red when it's in
whatever you also why does it do that
right what is what is the recite as it
turned red he
but green here and so sometimes you look
at the data and you can use various
tools and sometimes you use chemometrics
which is like fancy chemistry statistics
is a way to again you're looking at
changes of changes sometimes and you you
map the data and and sometimes you'll
look at a plot and I think some you know
even economic data there's lots of
people have all kinds of data and you
might plot it in a lot of different ways
bar chart pie chart Venn diagram like
you're just plotting your play and then
you know that there's something there
and you just you know sometimes you just
don't recognize the pattern or how one
thing influences another you just need
to step back from it for a moment and
literally could be literally I have
literally projected things and literally
just step in just gazed on it yeah and I
do feel like maybe that is a bit of the
creative thing where sometimes I've gone
to museums and pieces of art and you're
not sure that you're seeing what either
quote you should or what may be either
the artist thought or maybe you're
seeing something that that is not
intended but you need to get a better
look at it
and sometimes you step forward but
sometimes like there's been a few pieces
and the remember when I first time I
went to the effete see gallery and saw
say say like the the allegory of spring
or the Birth of Venus I had no idea they
were that large a photograph is a little
mom you know or you know something or
like the Mona Lisa's that's not have to
step it sometimes with the ones that
you're like that thing is the entire
side of the room right and you are
almost out in the hallway trying to
really see the full picture of all the
data and what it means in relationship
to other data and that's what often
times we do in science is that you know
because you might have a very simple
data set okay this thing turns red but
then the more sensors you add then you
have 17 of those things and then you're
trying to detect a hundred different
chemical so all of a sudden you have a
very complicated pattern yeah and you
need to kind of step back and say well
what does it all mean in relationship to
each other and so that part there is a
creative aspect
and how you visualize it you know and I
think sometimes I look at why did that
person paint that that way with that
shadow or why is that so abstract or why
did they sculpt it in that way in this
and then maybe it's you know maybe we'll
never know I do think that sometimes
artists take stuff literally to the
grave and they don't communicate the
intention or anything and sometimes you
know the point is you take from it what
you find important but you do sometimes
from every angle have to step kind of
back and see okay can I interpret in
different ways and I feel the same thing
with scientific data right yeah
different treatments and it's not as if
you're making it up but you are doing
different like again I'm gonna make it a
bar chart versus anion graph first and
and then what does that visualization
reveal about the underlying process and
the thing about chemistry and
crime-fighting or whatever is that
there's so many different ways that the
chemicals are involved in the
investigation right so let's say you are
called out like you still get called out
even you're a professor now not a crime
lab technician do you visit crime scenes
you know in a way I'm not because it's a
very stressful job and academia is
stressful in different ways but also you
know there's there's the cost-benefit I
get to do other things yeah okay all
right let's pretend that that's not true
what what what is on your mind when
you're called out to a crime scene what
are you looking for as a chemist what is
what good is the chemist out there at
the murder investigations well I think
it obviously depends on you know what
kind of background so typically when you
would get there you would get briefed by
who's ever in charge of the scene which
you know is not you
and so know it like when you watch on
the TV you're like what are the police
for CSI people are always running around
but like you know the background is
important of you know what should we be
looking for what shouldn't we be looking
for what's missing is just as important
as what maybe should be there and so so
what does that mean what what's missing
well let's say that you had somebody
that had a severe shellfish allergy
mm-hm and they had and you hear that
from family but yet you're not seeing
anything you don't see an EpiPen
right you might have you know you don't
even see a MedicAlert bracelet which is
really odd the dog that didn't bark you
know I mean you just also what's not
there or if the person was you know you
you hear from the Emmy that there's
someone was shot or somebody was stabbed
or they're strangled but there's
literally no weapon around so what's not
there it can be just as important as
what is there and so you know and the
same thing goes with any kind of
analytical data and I'm sure in physics
and astronomy at least from you know
friends that I have in those field it's
not only looking for what's present but
what is not there it can tell you a lot
too so if someone is poisoned or
something like that I could absolutely
understand the usefulness of a chemist
if someone's shot or knife does there's
still things for the chemist to do and
and chemical tests though in which
whether it would be a chemist there or
not but sometimes you know you might do
a gunshot residue and so presumptive
test for that or they would actually
collect you know swab hands very similar
to what some you know you get you get
screened for testing at the airport slap
your hands and then they might actually
take that swab and secure it and
transport it and then you maybe do some
some x-ray spectroscopy and some type of
you know atomic emission or absorption
spectroscopy to see okay are the the
metal components that you would
typically find in that in in gunshot
residue are they present and maybe at
what amount so that would be some level
of analytical chemistry but also let's
say that there
is you know you're trying to say okay is
this red brown stain is a blood earner
right okay then you would do some type
of chemical presumptive test or even
okay so it is blood but is it human then
you might do an immuno assay that would
you know illuminate so what does that
mean exactly how do you do and how do
you figure out whether blood is human or
not certain antibodies for different
types of animals would be present or not
present and you can do kind of like the
same type of technology as a pregnancy
test okay to kind of do it's really a
dipstick it does look a lot you know
they might do a lot of a pregnancy test
and you can kind of get an idea and say
oh it's you know which doesn't you know
that might lead you to another thing of
why they're dumb bloody or that there's
no dog right what's that you know or so
that I think that's another thing is
that there are lots of tests that it
folks do and so you know a lot of the
like even the presumptive and by
presumptive test I mean that it's just a
quick screening test that usually they
change color really visual really fast
to do and so sometimes there's real
popular ones for for scheduled drugs
that will you know if you roadside
they're very popular in highway patrol
or if you're screening something and
then you put a little sample a little
bag and you break a couple of ampules
and boom perfect right and you don't
even that's not even a professional
chemist that's like the couple on the
street can do a little sure chemistry a
lot of those have been developed yeah
right and then there's a lot of
development behind that to get it down
to it being that quote simple to do yeah
and so those types of tests are very
popular and then can again they're just
they're just you know providing quick
information to maybe make some type of a
command decision and so that's chemistry
chemical development of fingerprints so
say on paper you can use ninhydrin which
interacts with me
acids turns purplish pink color let's
make a charm teleport aerials so so you
can get fingerprints off of paper that
ya visualize so it'll stay on the
material yeah but you can visualize you
know the this this print matter and that
that actually came about when you know
folks were trying to do staining and
chromatography of proteins and amino
acids and then they were like hey this
might be useful for this yes and there's
many things like you know even see a
santa acrylate or superglue fuming that
she seal out on a TV that was a total
you know oops I mean we say that but
that's in its very useful kind of
technique and so that's a very you know
interesting chemical process that people
are still talking about in literature
about how exactly it works what's the
mechanism so that we know it works but
the chemistry the sort of individual
chemistry is not completely understood
we think we're pretty good pretty good
oh good I feel like that's a lot of you
know we have really good mechanisms
worked out or we think we've got you
know very strong evidence that this is
is this the action right until we don't
yep there's lots of in the fun you know
when I think about say slime which might
seem unrelated you know the kids and
adults let's face it love making with
the glue and the the borax love making
slime and just this year in chemical
engineering news you know people it was
you know still in literature in areal
chemists are still debating about how
that actually works and everyone thought
that that was a fissure lock and you
realize that no it's not actually bad
it's actually this instead I think that
you were familiar with this process of
slime making that I ever had make slime
okay so I make slime intentionally well
any any of your listeners that probably
have have kids have made it or so that's
the you know you're just basically like
Elmer's glue uh-huh and you add in a
little borax thing like a soap borax
soap the powdered soap old-school I
don't know maybe in in college in the
labs I had borax so and then you
basically mix it together and it becomes
the
non-newtonian fluid you would love this
like a I'm gonna go home yes no it's
super and they and you know it's super
fun and of course you know you can make
it with different types of polymers
clear glue white glue people put glitter
in it food coloring and like the spoke
slime but part of it too is even though
that process was like we know how it
works it's a polymer across polymerizes
blah blah blah were out of the door then
in the last couple years people are like
actually it's not this discreet
repeating you know cross-fertilization
we thought it was and actually does it
and so I find that really fun because
even though the best evidence at the
time people were very confident its
explained a lot but then you get better
you get better techniques to write and
we've seen that definitely in forensic
science where the trajectory of the
field has changed the instruments get
better you're able to see you know
literally see either smaller amounts or
levels of detail that change even small
amounts can revolutionize an entire
thought process would you say that
chemists chemical forensics is becoming
more important over time and crime
investigation or less I definitely think
more I think that you know the the use
of Science in in both criminal and civil
matters has really dramatically
increased in the last I would you know
definitely say in the last you know two
hundred years and definitely in the last
thirty and I think it's kind of funny
because one of my you know show as I
grew up with Murder She Wrote it kind of
demonstrates that over you're not show
was on I think for twelve years but when
it was on you straddled the era of
pre-dna and post and you see that in the
show the things that they talked about
in early episodes and oh we can get
fingerprints and like [ __ ] typing and
you're just like and then and then later
you know it's a very big revolution and
then you know even watching shows you
know Columbo where they you know
have a handgun they'll take a
handkerchief from their pocket and think
that they're you know somehow protecting
the print so they'll take a pen and
literally either the pen and stick it
down the barrel of the gun destroying
all the rifling but I think you know
even that visualization you can see how
even the perception you know and and how
shows are run now and now it's not
uncommon to see whole shows where they
show folks and tiebacks and they're
changing out their booties and there
they've got gloves that they keep
changing every you know so you've seen
the evolution of a field be mirrored in
you know television and movies and and
sometimes right and sometimes there's
artistic license taken but definitely
the field is that that reflects the the
big changes in the field which continue
I mean they march with the short with
the technology and do the chemists get
very involved with poisoning and things
like that is that mostly medical people
so yeah medical examiner really depends
on on the state I mean there's the
difference between if if you're doing
testing of say tissues and biological
fluids that's typically under the
control of the medical examiner and then
that that person would send tests out a
request samples be processed by
toxicology folks and maybe histology and
pathology they're looking at different
depending which like if is that tissue
or is it say urine or is it that kind of
thing so different types of materials
and different types of tests but if you
say you know you found some mysterious
white powder that actually might go to
trace I see right so once it's in their
body then maybe it's the mess yeah
that's a that's a different deal
but we find all sorts of chemicals
around then yes yeah and there was a big
workplace poisoning case in Germany this
year where a worker
I mean allegedly allegedly is you know
dozens of their co-workers and the last
one that kind of kicked off them
finding that first of all nobody had
known that workplace poisoning was going
on that span maybe you know he'd work in
that company for 40 years just killing
people for potentially because you know
this one worker brought their lines you
know in the break room you're putting in
the fridge you know your biggest concern
is you hope Susan doesn't eat your
wontons right and so they they open up
their thing and they see this white
powder that they didn't yeah and so you
know they you know took their supervisor
who you know at first was like oh it's
some kind of a prank or whatever and of
course me being a chemist and late
that's not a bright mysterious white
powder and so you know they they do some
testing in the mean time they also
installed CCTV and it seems as if they
did not maybe inform people that they
had installed cameras and so it turns
out they were they got this person on
video opening lunches for kids and
that's I think that's the thing that you
know the investigation is is gonna look
into of what was going on there
and you know they do testing and they
realized you know it was lead acetate
which is very sweet tasting but
incredibly dangerous and but then they
go back and they realize you know he had
so many different types of poisons
poisons too that could have potentially
mimicked you know especially this these
would be like a chronic poisoning not an
acute so it might look like co-workers
were ill and at the time the person was
arrested there was one co-worker in a
coma and one on dialysis so this this
poisoner was an aficionado like he
wasn't just eating to have just the
bucket of bad stuff but he had there's
new of different possible there's a lot
there to unpack all right and then they
start going back and looking at that
how many co-workers of this person had
died in the last twenty yeah years and
there's a lot I mean there's gonna be a
lot of work to do well alright so
chemists are gonna be fully employed by
toxicology and then medical you know
there's there's tons of stuff but I also
think you know my chemistry background
to working in analytical I you know did
you know image analysis and video which
seems a bit odd but then you know how
photography works how's digital data
works and how things are stored you know
an image is in some ways an image is an
image so if you have you know a camera
that's hooked up to a microscope versus
a security camera how do those work what
does the data mean how do you retrieve
the data and so I think just like in a
lot of other fields where you know you
you can translate the skills you learned
to this maybe new application right we
looked a bit tangent yeah you can do the
same thing definitely and it's not just
you know figuring out how a murder was
done or who did it there's presumably a
lot of chemistry involved and things
like finding the body or you know
analyzing old cases and old oh yeah I do
one thing I do say is yeah is that I
don't you know it was never my job to
solve anything that's definitely a big
thing it's like that's the police's job
right but we you know you might say okay
is this possible and the thing would be
like yeah yeah you know or provide some
data but I think with yeah I mean I
think some of the most interesting stuff
that comes out is trying to find like
clandestine grave graves and how do you
find when people believed or people had
been there right and so trying to
develop you know chemical tests and of
course geologists do this allows fires
you know types of imaging and trying to
look at and even you know different life
scientists of how different plant grows
and then entomologist what kind of bugs
are there they trying to locate those
things and and trying to map those you
would think I mean even I sometimes like
is there is that a big problem there
that's been graves it turns out yeah
or trying to so I find Destin Grave this
is not supposed to be a grave that's
pretty great but yeah yes I get that
body in your yard and you didn't yeah
but in actually in early so we're in LA
now no it's just a case that happened
where someone discovered a decaying
skull in their backyard and then I
walked up and brought it to a police
station and the police at first you know
this was just reported by LA Times think
it was yesterday and the police were
like that we thought it was a prank at
first cuz well you know my thing is like
so if you find that don't move it don't
move it right and you know the police
will come to your house possibly you
don't want the police to come to your
house and so I think that's the thing is
you know sometimes there's those types
of endeavors or when you have missing
people or you know and it could be it
could be historical I think there's also
you know kind of historical forensics
where you might be trying to investigate
a certain event and trying to really get
now that again technology advances in me
we can start you know finding certain
mass graves or when you know certain
sites that things that people thought
would occurred or sometimes there was a
case that I that I wrote about for my
column that was like Renaissance era
poisoning potentially that was that that
was the rumor it's a long time ago
oh yeah and the rumor was you know this
is the Medicis court in florence which
was just a hotbed and are intrigued and
and all the stuff and and there was this
rumor that this you know these these
these folks philosophers and poets had
been poisoned and in in an odd way or a
good way it's I feel weird saying that
but there are certain poisons that just
they stay with you like state they're in
there literally in the bone okay or in
you know certain amounts that get
preserved and so it was really
interesting work that they did because
they had baselines say arsenic levels
that just take it you know that's
everywhere
that's the naturally occurring or
element
and it can be in drinking water it can
just be around so there's that that
really small baseline quantity and so
they had that kind of environmental
background of what was kind of just
present at the time because arsenic is
not some complicated molecule it's it's
not an element yeah one atom and so you
know they have that baseline and and you
can get that in a lot of ways you know
you we have a lot of artifacts in that
period I mean the stuff is just
literally everywhere
but then you know they did some
interesting work or they found that for
definitely for one of the the two
courtiers the amounts that they then
found were like way beyond what they
found in kind of separate remains that
would have just been more like yeah this
is pretty standard and it's you know
again that maybe then the leap of saying
this was a malicious poisoning that's a
that's a legal law enforcement thing but
when you look at the levels and you go
wow and they were the Medici you know it
it's now does that mean that it's it's a
criminal you know I mean again we're
also talking about an era where you
could you know and even much after that
you could go to a pharmacy slash chemist
and pick up stuff but nowadays you're
like I'm sorry you could do what you can
just go to the pharmacist and pick a
loser vector strychnine and cyanide and
and you know and so it's hard to say but
the levels are interesting to be like
yeah so that's someone needs to explain
I mean it's more about what's the
reasonable explanation that that's not
just casual like well we tell stories
about meta cheese and you know it's kind
of fun palace intrigue stuff but a
reigniting or was there really that much
poisoning going on I felt you know it's
when you look back on those things you
know people always say now that you know
a whole this this you know kids these
days or nowadays and I'm like yeah there
was some stuff going on right between
the Borges and the Medicis and you know
the stories that you hear but then I
mean that is that become almost
integrated into historical or and that's
why you know sometimes these the folks
that go back and if you look at like the
Egyptian houses and the Upper and Lower
Egypt that you know what is that with
great power comes great responsibility I
think with great power also
comes great shenanigans and there's just
a lot of you know potentially things
that have gone on and part of it is you
know Wow really you know like I remember
the first time I heard about the Borgias
I was like oh scandal you know and again
we think that that's very modern but
some of these things know it goes back
oh yeah and I think you know the the
kind of the nicknames that things get
like arsenic like inheritance powder
that's how common it was you know and
it's where you think about those things
or you know hemlock and and belladonna
and you know strychnine and you think
about all these things and how easy they
were to get right and how you know
so-and-so is uncle or whatever had a you
know gastro you know distress and then
you know took a long time and you know
this is also an Agatha Christie device
of you know sometimes it is artistic and
sometimes art is just marrying that you
know yes so and so aunt whatever did
have an eight month long illness and
then died and then someone so inherited
it heritage the house or you know some
small bequeath but yeah but then a lot
of times you you look back at the old
newspapers and you realized that that is
like the whole blocks the law and order
I always loved the tradition you know
the old school on order it says you know
or even an SVU now it says that little
proviso of you know this is not I mean
it may be similar or this is you know
ripped from the headlines I'm actually
and you realize we've been doing that
for a long time you know and some of
these cases you're like that's a little
too close to home
yeah well this is good let's switch
gears from being the investigators to
being the perpetrators let's put
ourselves in the contents of the
perpetrators so we can maybe working our
way historically works here like if so
if you were back in ancient times what
were the good ways to off your nemesis
you know besides just like bludgeoning
yeah let's go a little more subtle maybe
and that's the great thing about poison
right is it is at least presumably back
in two thousand years ago if you plugged
in someone it's pretty noticeable but
maybe you could poison someone and no
one would know and I think that that's
that you know when you have some of the
classic old-school poisonings they've
been around for a long time your hemlock
your your belladonna so what you want
don't you that presumably the trick is
you want something that the person
imbibing it wouldn't know about wouldn't
know about not too strong a taste course
how do you know it doesn't have to
slowly days you don't want to taste it
well I mean that's where the you know
kind of folklore and legend people I
mean I said that's the other really
interesting thing is when it comes to
poisons the certain things again that
people think are kind of quote modern
inventions poisons abort a fact that's
birth control attempts this is all been
well documented in in texts I mean as
soon as people could be writing down
things they were either writing down you
know how to kill how to not get pregnant
how to terminate a pregnancy or you know
oh wait we need to write down some laws
you know you know these types of and
Bill's of cell I think we're I think the
the historical folks would be like no no
bills the cells came for you know like
those kind of tracking things but all of
that when you look back at some of these
you know kind of some of our earliest
great has you know scientific texts and
and again at the time it was the best
they could do because you read some of
the things now and you're like that
would never have worked but you know
there was a lot of information and
sometimes again it was observed that
someone still ate this plant that was
grown by the river and right yeah and so
unfortunately and so that's why I like
that kind of information but poisons
certain types of poisons have been known
for a very long time and people may kill
each other with poisons in one way or
another whether literally chemical or
biological also you know and being
intentional and trying to infect people
you know I mean people were flinging
rotting corpses over wells and you know
leaving dead rats and water wells and
and trying to do different things and
also just kind of both poisoning for a
long
long time and one of the yeah one of the
things you hear about is carrying poison
not just through ingestion but you know
through a garment or a weapon or
something like that yeah how plausible
are those pretty plausible yeah you know
we've got I mean most folks know about
like kirari and and and darts and arrows
and things like that yeah and also you
know lots of Greek mythology and and
ancient plays you know we'll talk about
like a poison dress the poison dress
trope is really popular of you know kind
of saturating fabric and having it
somehow you know it now so like a
metaphor of having it be beautiful and
then I'm having it kill you and that you
covenant the person who wore the dress
would be the victim of death
yeah and sometimes you know or any
garment don't be a dress could be you
know frantic garment could be kind of
reminds me know and you even the the
crown so even you know Game of Thrones a
bit and it wasn't really a poison it was
hot molten gold but like you lust for
something and you covet it so much
symbolic there's a symbolic elements
right yeah but you know when you read
some of these plays like Medea and you
go so that and that again didn't come
from nowhere and what happened in Medea
I'm so again the poison the poison dress
trope where it kind of actually reads a
bit like like an a poem and then when
you think about open flames and how you
know and even flammable fabrics were
have always historically been a problem
for ladies as far as the types of
materials dresses are made out of in the
fact that there were so much fabric for
certain folks and that you know lighting
devices were literally open flames
everything so you know this kind of
danger of that and in the visualization
of that hole it looks good when you
dress catches on fire you know and but
even in a more artistic way to make a
statement like Hunger Game right there
for visualization but when you think
about there's lots of routes of exposure
you know there's there's ingestion
there's gas there's like through the
skin and so there's a lot of methods and
that also you know is interesting and
historically it goes way back could have
been something that you were touch could
have again like clothes
you know and you saw that the danger to
like World War one which is called the
chemists war some of the it's not really
called that by anyone who's not a
chemist right unless you're a story and
maybe you call it the chemists war but
also some of the challenges with some of
the earliest nerve agents and and today
is that they persist in the environment
and on your clothes well you know if
you're in a theater of war you can't
really start running around taking all
your clothes off I mean even in a lab
environment like labs say if anyone's
been through lab training knows that you
know if you spill something on yourself
you got to use you know shower but the
first you know you're actually supposed
to take off this garment because it's
keeping it against yourself and so that
that's definitely based in history or
fact with again with some flare and you
know the ancient Greeks really did love
their flare when it so yeah that's
definitely rooted in do you think that
it was an impetus for early chemistry
the desire to kill people and more
creatively I think finding out I think
it's fun it's it's funny because you
know when you think about maybe the
history of chemistry but in specific
analytical chemistry was to test
currency you know you're talking about
time where currency or things that you
could trade you had to prove they were
the chemical composition they were is it
gold as a silver and for a long time
salt was considered a currency and you
could trade and barter because it was so
damn expand we don't think of it
nowadays because it's like laughably
changed you can buy like a bucket of
it's like a dollar but is it what it
actually is this thing that you've
attached huge value to and that's one
big thing and then of course the other
one is we got to find out why people
keep dying yeah and so that's an
important question I feel like you know
in analytical there's definitely this
kind of you're trying to you know again
solve mysteries of either is this thing
what we say it is because either it's
going to be the the found a
an entire economy which can cause an
entire thing to collapse if the gold
isn't gold right or we have such a
problem with proving goods are what they
are which again as a foundation of
economy or again like the poisoning
thing and deborah blum did a great job
in her book poisoners handbook of
tracking why that was such a thing
because again in a foundation of the
size society you mean the poisonings are
were not that common that it was
literally but it's the confidence and
it's the security of society which is
very tenuous yeah and doesn't take a lot
of criminal behavior no I had a great
podcast with Mahan Narula
talking about digital money and you know
first you have to agree that it's money
right and national currencies are
struggling with that right now so the
perception of safety and security
whether it's in the economy or your
person that a lot of the earliest
chemical tests were based solely on that
on a level of trust of protection and
community and security of you know what
does that mean because we've we've had
to all agree in trust right and yet
trust can be violated yeah and so once
we get to the Renaissance if you're
Lucrezia Borgia yeah annoying cousin
what do you do like how do you how do I
go shopping for poison ooh yeah do I
need to make it myself well or you'd
have your your right hand person but
also you know your apothecaries and your
thing and I think there's always been
right there has always been challenge of
what does that old proverb the only way
to keep only way three people can keep a
secret is if two of them are dead no the
more the more co-conspirators that you
have and so sure if you can do it
yourself and keep your own counsel to
also but I think that's actually a
biblical phrase keep your own yeah so
then then that would be you know better
in that and so you know some of these
folks were actually quite good but also
you won't you know the important thing
to remember is at the same time that
these things are lethal and poisonous a
lot of the same things we're in
cosmetics in in in smaller quantities
they were considered medicinal it would
not be uncommon especially in an
affluent household you know when we
think of like I'm gonna open my medicine
cabinet and I've got acetaminophen and
aspirin and antacids and like nine types
of band-aids of various sizes and I've
got point mints like you have like this
whole spread especially in a big house
hood
well that was again in the equivalent of
that correct that would have been it
would not have been uncommon to have
some of these things and then also think
about pest control which was also you
know kind of a big deal and also that
you know the beginning of understanding
the pest role and disease and all of
that but it wasn't all so uncommon to
get rid of vermin just because they ate
your food and and even if they the
disease link came later you knew they
were eating your food they were eating
through your clothes they were you know
they were just pests and so how do you
get rid of that okay so it was totally
not uncommon for people to have buckets
of the crazy up in their house to also
be using it in some much smaller
quantity in a medicinal way again
whether it worked or not
this sounds like a very 1800s kind of
thing to me like was that the high point
for ingesting crazy substances as oh you
can go much earlier yeah you know and
it's kind of fun to go to museums and
you'll see these you know chests of
things and you realize that especially
again the more affluent the house or
whatever the equivalent would be of you
know middle class and and up and even a
even more precarious socio-economic
positions there were you know kind of
the community
medicinal chest right or things people
had access to so what kinds of things so
you know you just had to say so
different herbs and some of the things
that we would think now are like oh so
basil right or your flavoring agents or
things you know that or peppermint
different mints that we're soothing on
the stomach or let me do a combination
of you know a little bit of mint with
pennyroyal and add-in you know these
kind of concoctions that you'd inherited
from you know grandma whoever and it
just seemed to work
and again that the fun thing is from a
natural products thing there's a lot of
things that you carried forward in your
leg that actually did work and so we're
gonna now make it and manufacture it and
it's aspirin those some of these things
and and people go back to there's a
whole you know area of scholarship where
people go back into historical tests and
try to figure out what was this thing
and then test it you know against modern
or historic diseases and see that hey it
really did like you know even on a weird
way honey and my modification
antibacterial properties and honey I
mean it wasn't just this it wasn't a
weird thing or because it was sticky
like it actually it's served sorry I
didn't know the honey played a huge role
in mummification is that true yeah a
little bit there's lots of different
types of mummification protocols but but
some protocol is actually a thin layer
of honey and it did it did help keep
down some of the little bacteria friends
from getting a bit out of control that's
crazy to me because it seems like it's
sweet and nutritious and they would
attract all sorts of crazy but it's
jam-packed fool I mean it's another
chemical it's just you know we the
things like honey and coffee we just
don't think about of what they contain
okay and it's thousand chemicals and and
you know it's got all kinds of stuff in
there you know it's an animal product
honey you've got all kinds of cool stuff
in there that could be serving some
really interesting purpose like right
what are the animals doing with it I'm
not sure that they're making it so that
I can have it on my toast you know so
there's some really interesting and
against the active area of scholarship
you know in some of the plants that are
you know that people grow oh it's
ornamental it might be poisonous or it's
ornamental and it seems like you know if
I place it here keeps down these types
of pests and insects well it's you know
releasing this volatile organic chemical
and there's you know there's really
something in that that people have known
about in gardeners you know it's not an
accident that these very elaborate
gardens that were planned out plants
were where they were and it wasn't just
because they looked cool you know when
you talk to you know are you reading
these old historical documents you
realize oh that's why they're trying to
keep
down pests are trying to attract certain
certain things or you know certain
Gardens place certain things there
because if you weren't well you would
want your medicinal garden close to the
house you weren't gonna have to like but
like so and so like some of that
knowledge now we just again we have
better tools so we can kind of find or
dismiss you know certain things and I
think that's kind of the fun part is
that you can look back and say okay well
that that explains it
or you're like I have no idea why
everyone was put sprinkling arsenic in
her yeah why why were you couple doing
that well in nowadays we presumably know
a lot more would we be able to commit
the perfect crime with our chemistry
knowledge now hypothetically of course
we're not advocating anything here
you know whenever and I do I've done
some panels where you know how to commit
the perfect murder and things like that
it's funny because I never think it
comes with planning in that way in the
perfect murder weapon because sometimes
even even chemicals like succinylcholine
which is a really scary agents it's a
medical purpose it's that if it's used
it's probably because you're gonna be
intubated
annika and it's a it works on a certain
type of muscle where completely is gonna
paralyze it unfortunately the type of
muscles are also the ones that help you
breathe however if you're if you need
intubation they need to get that tube
down your throat like that there's that
and you're gonna it's all very well
coordinated right but if you use it for
nefarious purposes it goes very very bad
and for a long time you know it was such
an odd poison to use as a poison you
know again we have the ones that we've
developed a lot of tests for that we
know what they look like these are the
symptoms our tests you know we've got
very simple tests they're gonna be the
first run like arsenic you know say
carbon monoxide cherry you know your
skin turns like a cherry red there's
other types of drugs that would cause
cyanosis your skin would turn blue
but something like succinylcholine is
such a we I mean it's a very specific
application it's not you know one of the
heavy hitter poisons the historical
poisons that it literally isn't found
wasn't found I mean now it's been you
know the jig is up yeah because it just
was not commonly used so I guess the you
could at one time that would that really
went under the radar and you can get
away with some stuff because nobody's
looking for I mean so if you're
poisoning somebody you might want a
chemical that disappears from the body
rapid metabolism which which
succinylcholine that that can be an
issue another one would be some of your
say your drug facilitated crime
molecules
yeah like scopolamine which I wrote
about recently where again not only does
it is it an issue because the metabolism
can be fast but one of its effects is
memory loss Oh perfect and it affects
your ability so by the time you might
even realize or even if you do that
maybe I should seek medical attention
three days later and you know whether a
metabolite could be found or which
metabolites I mean that so the drugs
action itself limits its ability to be
found and that's a big but that's no
there's a whole area of scholarship you
know going with that one and you know
really seeking out so every new drug or
new poison
you know requires another sort of people
like myself who develop a method like
it's a race it's a race against time you
know somebody comes up with something
and you've got to find a test for it so
today's perfect murderers tomorrow's you
know easily solved crime but yeah gotta
keep at it occur
same thing with inheritance pattern I
mean sure I got that nickname it for a
lot of times people were able to get
away with some really you know
outrageous stuff and then he does a lot
of these even if they disappear from the
body because they're metabolized they
have some other effect on you know like
you turn red like you say there could be
other effect but even if they're
metabolized as long as we you know the
other important area of scholarship is
really understanding that metabolism
because even if you can't find the
parent kind
anymore you can find all of its little
metabolites in certain ratios and then
it's like it's indirect but it's very
good evidence right and there's tons of
those and so again that's a good it's
the application of building a technique
does depend on that good old not even
old fashioned that clinical metabolism
really getting the mechanism and the why
so you can build a better test and it
all you know to me it all comes together
full circle of I'm an applied scientist
but the reason I can build better tests
is I have to understand the basic
research the in the clinical
applications and them and the routes in
order to get to the point where the
little tests that everyone takes for
granted that's so simple comes back to
the science it always comes back to that
you wrote this wonderful little snippet
in one of your columns that is relevant
here with its red color bubbles and
sweetness cherry Lambrini is a popular
tipple it is also a good disguise for
the sweet killer ethylene glycol
oh what a my favorite aslan glycol it
was another one that for a long time
went under the radar and antifreeze anti
feature it is it is an amazing and so of
course you know get easily easily
obtained I mean you can buy literally
gallons of it now you know the reason
why - it's not actually that weird green
color then battler they color it because
they're like hey don't drink this it's
antifreeze right because it's incredibly
dangerous yeah and of course the danger
like that is that it's very sweet like
at lead acetate it's a very sweet thing
and so how you disguise it if you're
trying to poison someone much like say
one of the lot of also plant based
poisons are alkaloids and they can taste
very bitter and so where do you hide it
right right and so that's why you know
of course even in cinema you see a lot
of these poisons in red wine or
elaborate cocktails or elaborate yes we
party or you know the some kind of thing
where it's like you're gonna freeze a
Negroni you know you're going to I mean
but you know antifreeze would be so
sweet that that kind of
cocktail there was a big case where it
was hidden in like a pro Paulo or like a
Gatorade cuz Gatorade is also cutie so
do you want to hide it in something else
that was sweet or you want to balance it
maybe I'm thinking more of a mixologist
rather than a killer right and I think
that that is your first mistake no you
want you in a terrible murderer you want
like ready for expecting sweet okay like
this this husband and wife you know I
mean it like my wedding toast made it
really this is a real case and I go to
wedding toast is mayor mayor marriage
never be described as perfect by date
lined because no but in this case made
such a sweet beverage that adding you
know a little bit a little bit of
antifreeze isn't it's gonna disguise it
you wouldn't want to add something like
strychnine right um it's two years that
would somebody would drink it first of
all there's you know the white powder
you'd really have to work to get it
dissolved but also that that bitterness
would seem odd right so if you know if a
friend was a Negroni drinker I'm not
gonna put antifreeze in it right because
the minute it hits the palate so sweet
it's off
they were like who've made this yeah and
they dumped it in you know and so part
of it is you you want to do like
dissolves like and of course you have
the really dangerous ones that are
colorless odorless tasteless which of
course is dangerous for the person I
make me just what the doctor ordered for
the villain and so there's a list of
those things actually a nice little
review article about you know the seven
most about about seven cup in homicide
poisonings okay and you know it's it's
it's weird or it's not weird but just
like everything else things are in vogue
yeah there's fashion though right you
know if so and again it also becomes of
how easy it is to get again because you
don't remember a suspicion you know I
mean that's part of it good
old-fashioned gumshoe intelligence
police work right of just amassing
information
and there was a really old case that
involves strychnine where a person went
to you know you could just go to a store
and buy it because again for pests if
you're getting rid of rats and I mean
it's it's still utilized in these kind
of poisoned wheat sprinkle it around and
so the shop owner was like yeah you did
come in and you did buy that and you
bought it you know and and that was you
know that was you know almost 200 years
ago so I mean and then of course there
there was a hundred fifty years yeah
there was a hundred fifty years ago and
then there was a test there was so again
these preliminary tests of looking at
these things then there there was that
and they discovered that but again of
the tests were done later right the
tests are always you know later then you
just went and you you went to every
place that that sold it you looked on
the farm and yep yep she was here that's
Wednesday yeah you know the good
old-fashioned kind of gumshoe stuff and
even I think that's the thing is that
even when you have the test people are
still gonna want to but where did they
get it yeah as long as we live in a
world where there's a lot of records
that are like everything we do yeah so
it's becoming harder and harder to
commit a good murder and yeah and I
think you know the records so when
people ask me about you know conveying a
perfect crime and some really elaborate
scheme I think the better thing is that
when when people have keep it simple
stupid yeah we've gotten away with
something quote-unquote it's really a
kind of sometimes a perfect storm of
incompetence sometimes of just low
response time certain things weren't
collected that should have been you know
the that maybe the maybe the
investigative officers made mistakes or
there were accidents or again that could
have been some level professional
incompetence the prosecuting attorney
declines I mean there's there's almost
like a perfect storm of things that can
occur where
it's you couldn't plan for that though
unless you literally did the
investigation of like it needs to be on
the corner of Sepulveda and like this
time of night between a shift change
like and then you that out almost how
did you find out do you know they're
pulling your Google search records and
that kind of stuff
and so it can be the more you plan the
plan reveals you're mouthing it's true
that's good point yeah but some others I
sometimes I get mail from prisoners who
want like me to give them a free copy of
my book or something like that so they
can't get it yes yeah and part of me
wants to help them out of course because
yeah they're in prison and they want to
improve themselves but but when you get
mail from prisoners it always includes
their prisoner number and look up what
hey and so way more exciting mail and
idea so far the ones I've gotten it's
not like you know mail fraud like
there's really bad things that these
people did this one I it pretty clear
that he killed his grandmother and like
they never found her body she
disappeared and from staying with him
and things like that but you know he got
a he got in prison for a related thing
but they never found her body and we had
to get rid of the body that's the other
thing yes well that's I've committed the
perfect crime you got a lot of options
but you know there's also weaknesses
body transport can be where you get
caught mmm you know there's there's key
cases where moving people and our bodies
is when you got pulled over for that
broken taillight and so there's you know
those taillights get broken anyway
surpri or some ourf speeding or a
parking fine or you know something like
that and so but then okay you move it
then you've upped the number of people
that see you and especially now with
CCTV and parking garages and just the
street and stoplights and and you know
one of the first things that folks will
do is they'll pull cameras from as many
locations as they can and someone's
going out to sit through at all so all
of that literally just the transport can
be hard and also I would advise because
this is actually a real case
don't Google best disposal Speights in
Los Angeles County can you go to the
dark web and you know do this without
just saying but also you know again it's
are you gonna bury it in your house are
you gonna transport and that's it you
know that that time leaves you open and
vulnerable there was a different case or
someone but like disposal type things
and they paid cash but they went to a
store with cameras and then for some
reason they wanted to use their club
card so they could get a discount okay
you cannot make these things out of
human behavior there's a selection
effect of these are ones we've caught
but you know on the other hand but I
think you know there's there's chemical
disposal methods
I mean acid or base there's fire
you know it's trying to obliterate it
that way there is you know I'm gonna it
would seem very difficult to incinerate
a body if you didn't have the right
equipment oh no you can do it I think
right out first I think time and and you
know where you're at and how much how
hot you can get things that get I might
shorten the time so if you're out if
you're in a cabin in the woods this
might be a way to go maybe but then you
know why is there a huge smoke thing
coming from that person's got I mean I
think there's always you know that you
can't what you can't plan for is someone
that decided to do them and their friend
hiked past your remote cabin and see you
carrying that thing rolled up in a
carpet out to the bonfire right you know
and even even the cases where and in in
recent years you've had it you know it
used to be the the cliche was no body no
crime you know was at one time harder to
prosecute those things but almost with
the advent of as much data and how
everything you know is kind of logged
and you have to kind of access certain
records you know unless this person is
totally ghosted or everyone yeah and
then gone completely off the grid which
is really really hard to do they're dead
and that's not a and then you look at
the person's behavior and and how they
would you know kind of carry on their
life meant there's they're not accessing
their banker card they didn't do a major
withdrawal they're not their credit
cards aren't being used their cars still
there I mean all of these things then
it's reasonable to conclude something
has occurred and so with again like
again the the ramp up of technology and
sometimes you know that there are
concerns about privacy and things like
that are legitimate but at the same time
it's like you know maybe a couple
hundred years ago maybe even fifty or
sixty years ago people would have been
like nobody knows minds your to go away
but now it's like no digital signature
means that aunt Glenda you know that is
that's you know it's just so hard to see
grace is that the crying labs are backed
up by months or years right now make it
easier I mean I think that I think that
that's the other challenge right so you
know the again it's a practical
administration problem and and we've
seen unfortunately we've seen that
manifests itself especially with sexual
assault test kits and with sexual
imitations while you're talking
warehouse is full of kits and there was
a great bunch of work where they've just
not been analyzed analyzed because again
the backlot the cost combination of
those factors but when they've gotten
the funds had actually gone through and
there was I believe it was in Michigan
they did all of this work analysis
because they got this funding and and
they were able to process all these you
know backlog kits and they found a
number of serial predators and you know
when you you look at the data again you
come back to the data and you look at
these numbers and you look at the I mean
again I'm not I'm not over saying you
what I'm saying warehouses full of stuff
that it's just again they do get away
with it not because you didn't leave
evidence behind but because of you know
limitations and staff instruments
budgets
right and it's it's shocking and somehow
so ordinary to say that but that
absolutely influences like every other
type of analysis
it absolutely influences what you can do
sure
you know I always like to end on a more
or less optimistic note and that was not
it as we as the wrap things up you know
I did want to say like I hope that most
of your students go into lives of
fighting crime rather than they seem
prepared for either one but you know
presumably the ones who are best
prepared would be good at either one but
are we is it is it exciting frontier for
chemistry now and in catching bad guys
in better and better ways I think I like
to think of it maybe is keeping us safe
and there's again not just catching bad
guys but I think also the things that we
think about are just you know kind of
workplace contaminants or environmental
your accidents or you know as you know
let someone who lives in Austin Texas we
just had this boil water notice what was
the boil water notice there was a wheel
the water you had to boil all the water
because the processing plants weren't
able to to function it the way they
could and when again like a storm or you
know again a hurricane you know it
doesn't have to be malfeasant and and so
when I think about my students and even
the work I do which would still be
forensic even if it's not you know
duplicitous is that it's in the business
of keeping us safe and being able to
have confidence in in the things that we
take for granted our food and our drink
and our air and I think that being able
to have the skillset to keep you know
yourself safe or at least be able to
look at the data and make good choices I
feel like you're you're giving you're
empowering folks and so that's kind of
how I look at what I do rather than the
opposite most people don't want to kill
people or even catch bad people that is
one of their lives drink their water and
eat their their kale smoothies and no
and there
they want to fit you know and and so
that's how I look at it is is you know
even though the CSI and the forensic
stuff is you know sexy and people
finding it interesting for the most part
what we do is is it's this mundane stuff
that that you just want to be able to
you know your milk is gonna be good your
water is safe to drink and you know
you've got a safe train station to walk
through with no contaminants I mean
that's really so in some small way I
think a lot of scientists you know
they're in general I think a lot of
scientists are I just want to help
people whatever small way that is and
we're thankful for it ray viryx thanks
so much for being on the podcast thank
you
[Music]
you
[Music]